so we're talking about the long essay
section on the AP u.s. History exam in
the first video on this essay we talked
about kind of general strategy for how
to approach the essay you've got 35
minutes to write it so I recommend you
spend five to ten minutes planning and
25 to 30 minutes writing so the question
we've decided to answer is some
historians have argued that the New Deal
was ultimately conservative in nature
support modify or refute this
interpretation providing specific
evidence to justify your answer so we've
come to the conclusion that there are
three different ways we could go with
answering this question now we could say
yes we think that the New Deal was
ultimately conservative we could say no
actually the New Deal was quite radical
or we could say it was both or neither
somewhere in between so we then took the
opportunity to just kind of brainstorm
things that we might bring up in an
essay like that what kinds of facts are
related to the New Deal and we recalled
that the New Deal was this series of
programs implemented by President
Franklin Delano Roosevelt in his
administration to try to combat the
Great Depression and it contained a real
alphabet soup of agencies which aimed at
trying to get work to Americans to help
Americans who were struggling and also
to try to make sure that something like
this never happened again but we noted
that the New Deal ultimately didn't
really work partly because the Supreme
Court rolled back some of its agencies
as being unconstitutional and partly
because it was actually world war two
that got the United States out of the
Great Depression so let's take a minute
and just pinpoint some of the themes
that have come up as we've brainstormed
these possible pieces of evidence well
it seems like we definitely want to talk
about just kind of the system of
government in general
and definitely the economy the economy
is really the heart of the Great
Depression what else can we think about
well as historians were always
interested in questions of race and
class and gender so we're always
wondering how did things affect people
who are white differently than people
who were black how did it affect rich
people differently than poor people or
women differently than men and it's just
a really useful way of thinking about
how benefits in American society might
not necessarily accrue to everyone okay
so these are some possible themes we can
cover now let's ask ourselves whether in
each of these themes the New Deal was
something that was radical or something
that was conservative okay
government so was government in general
kind of radical or was it kind of
conservative in this time period well I
think there's a good argument to be made
that government was conservative in this
time period because the United States
didn't give up the democratic system
you know many nations in the world did
in this time period think about Germany
which became fascist in this time period
so there's still a commitment in the New
Deal to keeping the governmental system
of democracy alive even though the
economy has tanked no one has said well
this is a clear example that democracy
doesn't work so let's try being fascist
you could also say that there is a
radical change in government in this
time period because the government is
now taking on roles it has never taken
on before so there's just a completely
new level of intervention in the economy
by the government that you could say is
completely radical all right how about
the economy well I think there's a good
argument to be made that the New Deal
was conservative in the economy because
the United States didn't give up
capitalism you know just like the United
States decided that they weren't going
to give up democra
see they were going to give up the
system of capitalism itself the New Deal
instead with things like the NRA or
maybe Social Security was instead
designed to kind of shore up capitalism
to solve the problems of capitalism
instead of maybe going toward a
completely government-run economy or
completely people led economy like in
communism but you could also say that
the economy in this time period is
really radical because again there's
this massive government intervention
there's a complete rewrite of how the
United States thinks about what the role
of government in the economy is okay how
about race I think it's pretty easy to
argue that the New Deal was conservative
in terms of race because very few people
think of the 1930s as this major turning
point for civil rights for
african-americans or any other group you
know in most cases the economic pressure
of the Great Depression meant that many
people who are minorities many women
actually lost their jobs because of a
racist idea that white men were more
deserving of those jobs so you might say
that yeah the civil rights movement
doesn't happen till later you could also
talk about maybe job loss on the flip
side you might talk about the
opportunity that the Great Depression
gave to talk about real economic
disparities between whites and other
races you might even say you know
Eleanor Roosevelt in this time period
was a essential advocate for civil
rights especially making sure that the
benefits of the New Deal trickled down
in whatever way they could to minorities
and that the New Deal itself was not
intended to separate african-americans
and whites in jobs in its benefits
it was mostly administrators at the
local level who might have prevented
african-americans from reaping those
benefits okay what about class
think this is a really important one
because the New Deal is all about the
relationship between the rich and the
poor and I think one thing that the New
Deal does that is very revolutionary I
know I'm flipping the order here is it
really makes people question the idea
that wealth is earned completely without
relationship to one status in life right
in the period of the Gilded Age many
people said things like oh well you know
the wealthy people the white people they
are in a better position in life because
they're more deserving they've worked
harder they maybe even be racially
superior according to the logic of the
time and then the Great Depression which
affects so many people
really makes people rethink this idea
that wealth and status are connected
with one's personal worth so you could
say it really kind of up ends this idea
of social Darwinism that you know the
fittest the best in society are the ones
who are prospering but you could also
say that in terms of class once again
the New Deal was nothing like the
revolution in Russia there was no
massive redistribution of land there
wasn't this great sense of class
consciousness and workers uprising
instead it pretty much continued the
patterns of social classes that existed
before in terms of women's lives in the
New Deal you might say that you know
things for women might even have been
worse in this time period than in the
1920s because again as jobs contracted
those jobs were often reserved for white
men in fact some of these programs like
the Civilian Conservation Corps were
only for men only for people who were
considered breadwinners on the radical
side you could say that the New Deal
opened up many new positions for women
in the federal government for example
Franklin Delano Roosevelt appointed
Frances Perkins the first-ever cabinet
secretary who was a woman and you might
also even talk about Eleanor Roosevelt
and her own prominence you know she
really transformed the position of first
lady which is something that is going to
be important throughout the rest of the
20th century so you may be noticing here
that there are good arguments for going
either way and the fact is either way
you argue this or even if you choose to
go this route of modifying or saying
either or both radical and conservative
they're both right so at this point you
just have to decide which way you want
to write about and then marshal your
evidence for your essay now we'll get to
that in the next video